more than 30 lawmakers are demanding an
investigation into what they call
suspicious activity on capitol hill one
day before the attack
in a letter to security leaders they say
this they quote witnessed an extremely
high number of outside groups in the
complex on tuesday january 5th
and the visitors quote appeared to be
associated with the rally at the white
house the following day
the acting house and senate
sergeant-at-arms and the capitol police
did not return
a request for comment from us virginia
democratic congresswoman abigail
spanberger signed that letter
and joins us now to discuss
congresswoman thank you so much for
joining us you know it was so
disturbing and upsetting to see police
officers taking selfies
at one point they seemed to be opening
barricades and doors to say right this
way fellas
so it was just really tough to watch
those visuals
now you've signed the letter what
concerns you most what did you see if
anything
well i want to start with one of the
most heart-wrenching things that i saw
which is
while there are disturbing photos of
some of capitol police officers taking
selfies and opening
doorways i was trapped in the gallery
as these insurrectionists were trying to
break through and i saw capital
police officers barricading the door
with tables
and benches desperately trying to keep
them out desperately trying to protect
the lives of those inside myself
included and i'm forever grateful
and in the lead up to january 6th uh
what i witnessed was
members of the public people who had no
business being in the capital
during the the shutdowns that we have
because of the pandemic
um milling about in the office buildings
and so just notably since march because
of covet 19
the building has been closed to the
public so it is
uh easy to note when there is a real
departure from that and
on the day before the insurrectionist
attack
there were people uh in the building
where i work uh
i i noticed them when i was coming back
from the capitol just people
milling about in the halls um and
dressed in apparel that they were
presumably in town for uh the the
event that they ultimately attended uh
and so it was
notable and and certainly concerning uh
you know initially from a pandemic
perspective but
um ultimately because of the
insurrectionist attack
yeah i mean it's it's terrifying the
more we see the more we hear i'm sorry
that you had to go through that your
democratic colleague
mikey cheryl says she believes that some
of these people had
help from some of your fellow colleagues
some of your fellow congress people
do you believe that's the case well so
that would be the only way that these
individuals would have entered the
building
um i have uh been told that they entered
with members of congress
you know notably some of the challenges
that exist is that members of congress
have a lot more liberties when it comes
to walking around the capitol when it
comes you know and understandably so
uh but even during a shutdown period
because of
the pandemic it was limited to staff but
members of congress
are able to bring people in uh we do
have the
uh i guess the they give us the courtesy
of whoever we deem can come in despite
the closures
uh they they allow it um or certainly
don't argue back
so the way that these individuals would
have entered the capital in the first
place would have been with a member of
congress
making that possible now the letter has
been signed by more than 30 democrats
but so far
no republicans have signed the letter to
my knowledge have any of them
expressed any of their concerns about
that to you either
privately uh so
in the larger discussion of all that's
been happening with the
the domestic violent extremists who were
uh who waged an attack on our capital um
you know i don't know that
they are or not thinking about it
privately but um
it hasn't risen up to the level of a
discussion at this point that i have had
with any of my republican colleagues
we've been focused on the
articles that were brought forth
yesterday and their intent
on how they would be voting and what did
you make of the president's comments
yesterday you know a week ago he was
telling the crowd
fight like hell we'll go to the capitol
i saw interviews with people
in the crowd congresswoman who were
going they thought president trump some
of them were actually leading them
yesterday he says mob violent mob
violence goes against everything i
believe
everything this movement stands for no
true supportive mind could ever endorse
political violence
what do you make of that do you think
that his supporters believe him when he
says that now
you know those those comments i think
are arguably two months too late if not
four years too late
this is a president who after the
horrific events in charlottesville said
there were both people
on both you know good people on both
sides after a woman was killed in an
attack and there were
literal nazis walking through the
streets chanting anti-semitic
slogans um
this is time and time again when he's
had the chance to denounce violence when
he's had the chance
to dial back his rhetoric um he hasn't
done so and it's created
a space for these domestic violent
extremist groups
to really take hold uh and it's created
a space for conspiracy theories
to to begin to really uh
take root in our society and so so much
of what he's done with this notion of
stopping the steel
and frankly so many of my colleagues who
didn't stand up against that and say
this is the truth the truth is
vice president biden is now
president-elect biden yeah i think
everybody's getting that message now
congresswoman do you feel safe on
capitol hill
right now you know i'm grateful i'm
grateful for
the security forces that are there i'm
grateful to all of the members of the
national guard who have been deployed
including many virginians
but i think it's an evolving process and
we're going to see into the future
what changes permanently may need to be
made and certainly
this is a long-term challenge addressing
domestic violence
extremism in our country is something
that we're
we're going to need to take seriously
and anyone who didn't get the message my
goodness on
january 6th my i implore you to
recognize this is a long-term threat
that we all need to be united in
fighting against
all right congresswoman spanberger five
people lost their lives but it could
have been so much worse
thank you so much for your time this
morning